it was a year after my injury and I was
in this space as a young 20 year old
where I was kind of learning that I had
this potential to influence simply by
using my story but yet at the same time
underneath all of that there's still was
element of the darkness and so it was
excitement when I got out of the army in
2006 because I was now going going into
the world and I was gonna pursue my
dreams of being a motivational speaker
but yet shortly after it became flesh
trading because my dream wasn't
happening the way that I envisioned it
in my head society is looking at you as
one particular thing they're not looking
at you as assigned and I looking at you
as a friend and I looking at you as an
individual that laughs or cries or feels
they're looking at you as a veteran and
I just started thinking to myself well
maybe this was foolish of me to think
that I could be a motivational speaker
and then all of a sudden later that year
in August I get an email from a friend
of mine and it says something about
auditioning to become an actor on a show
you know when they told me else was be
on the show for three months you know I
thought three months that's mentally
when I prepared for but needless to say
you know as I started to kind of learn
how to become an actor and it turned
into a three-year role I you know I
learned so much about myself